ce robot est un robot qui pèse 500 kg
qu'à une capacité de transport de 750 kg
une autonomie de 8 heures
il va à une vitesse de 8 km on a alourdi
le fantassin au fur et à mesure des
années avec les différents systèmes
qu'ont lieu un ami le poids moyen sûr
que doit transporter 1 fasse un
fantassin et entre 25 et 30 kilos en
plus dans des théâtres comme le théâtre
malien où on a une consommation d'eau
journalières d'à peu près 10 litres
quand on déploie une unité à pied ça lui
permet de s'alléger de sa charge et de
mettre une partie de sa charge dans le
robot et de pouvoir ainsi gagner en
mobilité
plus vous appréhendé le terrain et plus
vous êtes en capacité de réagir à
l'imprévu de connaître le terrain de
savoir aussi se mettre à la place de du
potentiel ennemis de dire qui peut
arriver par laquelle visibilité il aura
de mon dispositif virtuel mah permet
cette capacité c'est-à-dire de se
projeter n'importe où sur le terrain de
façon à avoir cette vision d'ensemble
donc là sur le grand écran vous avez la
même vue que ce que j'ai dans mon casque
là j'ai un crayon est de droite je peux
dessiner donc l'intérêt de cet outil
c'est qu'on a une véritable immersion en
trois dimensions avec l'image box qui
est une caméra qu'on a placés sur un
véhicule militaire don effectué un
relevé de 2 km en une demi heure
ensuite nous avons passé les images
reçues dans un logiciel et après 20
heures de traitement nous avons obtenu
le rendu 3d que vous pouvez voir à
l'écran donc il représente le terrain
jusqu'à présent pour faire un road book
un plan de chemin les géographes parts
et puis ils sont dans le convoi ils
prennent en fonte en photo les lieux
intéressants les croisements ou ça une
fois revenu ils font leurs leurs
fichiers avec ce système là le
une équipe deux géographes n'est pas
forcément d'être obligé d'être présente